let's bring in new york congresswoman
nicole manley attack us for more on this
so we see that kathy hokel the governor
is going to lift restrictions at least
to a degree there in new york it means
that people won't have to wear masks and
private businesses anymore private
businesses won't have to ask for the
vaccine passport it's not going to apply
to schools though and i'm wondering in
all of this congresswoman what's changed
the science or the politics well it's
interesting that you don't need the
masks now in businesses but you do need
them in school so certainly it's
political here
i believe because kathy hokel is in a
primary with somebody from the left
she's doing this to appease the teachers
union what i'll say is is that my
colleagues and i from new york we we've
been pushing and yesterday again we
wrote another letter to the governor
asking her to join the states of new
jersey and connecticut as you now
reported massachusetts in lifting these
mandates we believe that it should be
the parents choice on whether their
student their child is wearing a mask in
the classroom and that should be a
personal health decision made by
families not by a governor particularly
when you're seeing politicians like
stacy abrams maskless in a school for a
photo op you're seeing senator schumer
dancing salsa without a mask in puerto
rico you know it's the hypocrisy and the
double standard that i think americans
have had enough of and that is why
you're seeing so many come out and
really be vocal pushing for their rights
and freedoms i'll get to stacey aberbs
in just a moment because that's
something i do want to discuss with you
but
the move by kathy hokel and the
governors of new jersey oregon uh and
other states delaware included put them
at odds with the white house which is
still sticking by its guns in terms of
mass mandates here's jim sockey's
response to our jackie heinrich
yesterday at the briefing
these states i think it's important to
note they still allow for decisions to
be made by local school districts if a
kid or a parent chooses to wear a mask
or a school district decides they should
keep mass guidance in place and there
are leaders who are preventing them from
doing that local school districts have
always made these decisions that remains
the case you know i got to say that the
turnaround of blue states is remarkable
as is the difference between how it's
being covered when
mississippi and texas removed their mass
mandates the president of the united
states said it was neanderthal thinking
when glenn younkin the in the
commonwealth of virginia removed mass
mandates he was met with lawsuits and
yet when phil murphy does it it's met
with congratulations we're moving
forward we're getting back to normal
yeah it's i mean it's real hypocrisy and
i think that is why americans are so
frustrated even cnn's
health experts said that masked should
not be mandated in schools that it
should be a student's choice which
therefore means the parents choice so
important by the way
for social development for mental health
for
emotional health and particularly for
those young kids they're saying that
they need to be able to read the lips of
their teachers it's part of their
developmental uh growth so i think that
again let parents decide if their
children wear masks in schools let's get
rid of these mandy's one for once and
for all let's restore normalcy that's
what i've been advocating you know with
treatments with with antiviral
medication that's what we should be
focused on except that this is here to
stay and it's going to be an annual
annual thing and we need to just be
prepared to deal with it as best as we
can without all these restrictions and
mandates that are affecting all other
sorts of life from the economy to
education uh and mental health got less
than a minute left let's get to stacey
abrams who had initially said oh i took
the mask off for one photo then it turns
out no she headed off for much longer
than that she apologized for doing that
listen here
i took a picture and that was a mistake
protocols matter and protecting our kids
is the most important thing and anything
that can be perceived as undermining
that is a mistake and i apologize she
says that taking the picture was the
mistake taking off the mask actually
might have been the mistake but it
reveals a disturbing trend among
democratic politicians who slough off
the rules and then resort to
preverification and obfuscation and
clearly there's the sense that they
think people are stupid and aren't going
to figure out what really happened
yeah it's rules for thee not for me
that's how the democratic party rolls
but the bottom line is stacey abrams has
done more to lift the restrictions on
our young people this week by doing that
photo and showing the hypocrisy of the
left and that it's not based on science
it's just based on politics nicole
malley attack is good to see you we're
looking forward to seeing you again on
st patrick's day when you become nicole
o'malley otakus
see just a month for now see you then
thanks jillian